Hi, welcome back. In the last few
sessions, we've laid the foundations for
value investing. After the introductory
session where we talked about the Ben
Graham and the Warren Buffett effect on
value investing, we talked about passive
value screening where you look for
stocks that trade at low PE ratios or
low price to book or or have high
dividend yields on the assumption that
they will mean revert that they will
become better investments and
essentially earn you a higher return.
Then we moved on to contrarian value
investing where you look for stocks that
have fallen off their peaks, have had
something bad happen to them in markets
but have had no good reason for that bad
happening. In other words, their
fundamentals have held up and you try to
invest in those companies. In this
session, I want to focus on activist
value investing where you actually go
into companies and change the way they
run and hope to harvest the returns as a
consequence. And in particular, I'm
going to look at private equity, which
has become the player that drives a lot
of activist investing. Before we look at
private equity, it's worth noting that
activist investors come in multiple
versions. There are lone wolves. Now,
Carl Ians, Bill Amans of the world, even
though they are vehicles that they use,
they're individuals who push for change.
There are groups of institutional
investors who call themselves activists
who go in and push for change. Kalpers,
the California pension fund early in its
lifetime was an activist investing force
and you of course have private equity
and hedge funds who go in and target
companies and try to change them. The
key difference between activist hedge
funds and lone wolves is rather than
push to change the management, you know,
replace them, you often work with the
management in taking the company private
and then try to change the company in
conjunction with the management in
place.
lone wolves, institutional investors,
activist hedge and private equity funds.
Now, let's focus in on what activist
value investing is and what might allow
it to work and what sometimes can cause
it to break down. Here's what you do in
activist investing. You target a public
company where the status quo value
reflects how that company's run right
now. And implicitly, you're assuming
this company is not run right. It's not
run well.
and you think it could be worth a lot
more with different management in place,
changing the way the company's run,
different projects, different financing,
different dividend policy. Let's call
the first value the status quo value.
The value of the company as is the
optimal value being the value with the
changes put in. There's a gap between
the two. You as the activist investor
are trying to take advantage of that gap
by doing what? by coming in and changing
the way the man the company's run and
then claiming the difference between the
optimal value and the status quo value.
Of course, you might not succeed at
getting the management change. So, you
have to put an expectation of a
management change in to come up with
that difference. So, the essence of
activist value investing is changing the
way a company is run. Now, as we before
we embark on those, let's take a look at
the motives that private equity
investors often or activist investors
bring to the table when they target
companies. Much as I've talked about
changing companies, the biggest single
motive that activist investors site for
targeting a company is that it's
undervalued. Why might that be? Well, if
you have an undervalued company that's
badly managed, you have two things
working in your favor. You can fix the
management, increase value, but you also
have the undervaluation working in your
favor. But you look at the changes that
that activist investors plan to make. A
big chunk turn out to be capital
structure change. You want know
primarily increasing increasing the
amount of debt that a company carries.
It could be changing strategy, entering
new businesses, exiting other
businesses. It could be the sale of the
target or pieces of the target. or it
could be changes in governance,
management, board of directors. Right?
Now, as you look at those, you can
already see what a typical target
company is going to be in an activist
investing mission. A typical target
company will tend to have higher free
cash flows, high positive free cash
flows. Why? Because you need those cash
flows to service your debt, especially
if you're borrowing money to do the
investing to to take over the firm. High
free cash flows. Second, the company
needs to be cheap. Here again, your
measure of cheapness might be
simplistic, low P ratios, low EV debit.
Um, so typical target companies tend to
have high positive free cash flows, tend
to be cheap, and tend to have potential
for operating improvement. You say, how
would I know? Your company's margins are
well below the margins of your pure
group. Returns on capital are well below
the cost of capital. High free cash
flow, cheap, and potential operating
improvement. Now, of course, once you
get into the firm, you need to change
the way it's run. There's a lot on this
page. I won't go through every single
one of them, but essentially, here are
the five questions I would ask about any
company. And I could be an activist
investor or an outsider. First is how
well does this company manage its
existing investments? You know, because
you could bring in cost cutting and
devestatures to manage those assets
better. Are you investing optimally for
future growth? If you're in a business
earning less than your cost of capital,
you're in a bad business, you shouldn't
reinvest. In fact, reinvesting less is
better than reinvesting more. If you're
in a good business, maybe reinvesting
more will increase your value. Third, is
there scope for more efficient
utilization of existing assets? That
could increase your margins. Fourth, are
you building on your competitive
advantages? Your competitive advantage
show both in your profits and returns as
well as how long you can grow at a rate
higher than the growth rate of the
economy. And finally, are you using the
right amount of debt in funding the
firm? With young growth firms, your
focus is going to be just on two. Two
being are you investing optimally for
growth. With established growth firms,
it's going to be 2, four, and five. With
mature firms, your focus might be on 1,
three, and five. So depending on where
your firm is in the life cycle, what you
do to extract value to make it more
valuable can be very different. Now
that's the promise that activist
investors will go into these target
companies and change them. Let's see
what the actual record show and what
activist investors do with these
companies. On the governance side, here
are some of the changes that come about
when a company's targeted by activists.
Boards of directors tend to become
smaller and meet more frequently after
activist buyouts.
More directors are picked for their
expertise in the target business. You
have less directors for show more who
are business who know that business. In
terms of top management, the likelihood
of CEO turnover increases at firms that
are targeted by actors by about 5 and a
half%. Far more CEOs at firms that are
targeted get replaced than firms that
are not targeted. And CEO compensation
decreases for the most part after an
active targeting and becomes more equity
focused as opposed to cash. So there's a
governance change on asset deployment.
Less money is reinvested back. But
there's little evidence that activist
investors just strip companies down to
nothing. they do reinvest less often for
good reasons because you're in a bad
business now and when growth firms are
targeted by private equity investors
there is no evidence of a drop off in
R&D or a decline in what the company has
to do to deliver that growth. So much as
we have this prototype of private equity
investors as stripping down companies
and that is definitely true at some
private equity transactions for the most
part private equity investors tend to
refocus investments in existing
businesses. Now as part of that red
redeployment of assets there are
devestatures usually of businesses that
don't fit into your core. So many ways
companies after being targeted by
activist investors go back to their core
businesses and if they go into new
businesses they sometimes do it is to
augment what they do augment their
strengths. So on the investment side
there are changes on the finance on the
profit the and those changes show up in
profits. If you look at the margins in
the years before and after
an activist buyout, profitability
improves in the two years after. So the
two ladder columns are the after, the
two two columns in front are the before.
You can see that profitability improves.
So activist investors come in, they sell
off assets that are noncore, they focus
reinvestment
and they do cut cost to increase
profitability. Now on the on the
financing side it is true that there is
borrowing more borrowing after the deal
and if there's a weak link in activist
investing it might be the assumption
that you higher debt is always better
than lower debt. So if you look at the
debt ratios for companies in the years
before they're target and years after
it's undeniable that there's an increase
in debt after
uh after an activist targeting some of
that is because of limited capital
others is uh the other reason is
activist investors hope to benefit from
the leverage effect in terms of earning
higher returns. So there's more debt
after funding. Default risk tends to
increase and existing bond holders can
be adversely affected because the
existing lenders lend to a safer firm
and if they're not protected they can be
hurt after a private equity transaction.
And finally on dividend policy there is
more cash return both in the form of
special dividend/bybacks
and some cases there is a stripping of
the assets to pay these dividends.
That's often viewed as a negative on
private equity and in some cases it can
be if the assets being stripped are
essentially assets that should not be
stripped. The changes in governance
companies have you know smaller more
accountable boards and there's more
management turnover changes in the asset
base assets get added on devested it
changes in financing more debt and
increased dividends. So activist
investors do make a change but let's not
overestimate how successful they are. If
you look at the success rate of activist
campaigns
it's pretty low. You know if you take um
you know for instance sale of a company
only 32% of targeted companies actually
sell operating restructuring about
34.78% of companies restructure. More
dividends only about a sixth of all
companies pay more dividends. So you can
have a company targeted an activist
investor but in many cases the activist
investors either give up or they give in
and there's very little change overall.
If there's a critique of activist
investing it doesn't have enough of an
effect on the companies and much of the
gain seems to come from the price rise
that comes about after they've targeted
the company. They often get called on
their bluff and they can't carry it
through.
As for the question of whether activist
investors make money, this study looks
at the returns on stocks that have been
targeted by private equity investors
around the date of the targeting. Day
zero, the 13D filing is when you know
they've been targeted. First thing you
notice, the stock price starts to drift
up in the days before the filing.
Information is leaking out. I will leave
it at that. Insider trading perhaps
follows and the stock price drifts up.
But clearly there is a positive effect
on the stock price from being targeted
by activist investors.
The question is if you see the drift
that happens after the announcement is
can you and I take advantage of this
drift. Perhaps
you buy stocks after they've been
targeted by activist investors. You know
the announcement has been made. There's
still a little bit of a drift but it's
not big and there's enough noise in it
that you can still get hurt as an
investor.
So if you look at private equity you
know and how it generates value from a
transaction in addition to all of the
changes we talked about an increase in
the value of the equity. It is true
private equity investors also collect
money in the form of management fees.
The fact that there are many private
equity deals where everybody else loses
money but the private equity player ends
up making money because of the
management fees. But management fees are
a key component of how they make money.
But the making your equity stake more
valuable is the bigger payoff. If you
can buy a company and quadruple its
value before you flip it back and the
way you exit can be either by taking the
company public again or selling it to a
public company. That's the way you get
big winners. So management fees are part
of the game. But to be big winners,
private equity has to actually change
companies and get people to pay more for
these companies.
Now this is actually from a private
equity player. So take it with a grain
of salt to how private equity generates
the returns it did. It does. So you can
see the buildup. There's a the market
return it have made as a passive
investor. Then there's a timing effect
where private equity enters this this
company at the right time. There's a
sector effect. It picked the right
sector. There's a leverage effect. The
debt helps you and brings you to
comparable return. And then you see the
red alpha. The presumption in this graph
is private equity players are special.
They add to your returns. The red is the
additional return they deliver because
they're skillful. For a long time,
private equity had that reputation of
being an alpha generator.
But here's the bad news. Things are
starting to change. In this graph, you
look at private equity versus public
equity. Public equity, of course, is
buying stocks in the market. Private
equity is going through the private
equity players. The red column is the
private equity. In the early part of
private equity's life, and this graph
starts in 2002, but you could go back to
in the 1980s and 90s, private equity
consistently delivered returns, at least
in the aggregate, that exceeded public
equity. They focused on the right
companies. They made changes. There was
a payoff. That started to change. If you
look at 2017 through 21, and in fact, I
have the data through 2024. Private
equity at best is staying on par with
public equity and at worst is falling
behind. In fact, if you look at the
alphas, what you earn over and above,
you see the dropping off of alphas over
time from private equity. Now, this is
this graph goes through 2015. If you
extend it out to 2020, 2021, the alphas
have very quickly drifted down towards
zero. Private equity has increasingly
becoming a game where generating
additional returns, excess returns has
become difficult to do. But even in its
glory days, private equity has always
been a game where the returns are
diverse. Put simply, even in the glory
days, it's not like all private equity
funds delivered more than the market.
It's that the biggest winners delivered
a lot more. And you can see that in this
graph where I graph out with each type
of of of private equity investor what
the best returns, the worst returns, the
median returns. The median returns are
actually very ordinary. It's the very
best players in the game who are
delivering those high returns and
they're the ones who make the news and
then you form your views of private
equity based on those biggest winners.
Not every private equity player is a KKR
or a Blackstone. In fact, most of them
are very ordinary investors.
And even the KKRS and Blackstones, the
way they make money doesn't come from
winning on every single investment. The
biggest winners within their portfolios
carry their portfolios. So, private
equity has become increasingly a zero-
sum game. A game where you deliver
returns that you expect to deliver. the
biggest winners might still remain the
big there's some continuity in this game
but the biggest winners still stay
winners because their best deals deliver
enough money for their portfolios to do
well
ultimately though I think the fading of
private equity some of it can be traced
to the fact that private equity today is
so much bigger in terms of capital
invested than private equity 10 years
ago 20 years ago we might have oversold
private equity to investors and in the
process attracted so much money that the
basis for alphas might very well have
dissipated.
But if you decide to play this game of
being a private equity investor, here's
what you need. First, you need to have
lots of capital. You can't be a private
equity player with $100,000 in your
portfolio. You need hundreds of millions
of dollars. Otherwise, what company will
take you seriously? You need to know the
company you're targeting well in terms
of its culture, in terms of its
management, in terms of the change you
want to make. You need to understand
basic corporate finance.
What does that mean? You need to know
what separates good projects from bad
projects. When more debt is good for you
and when more debt is bad for you, you
need persistence because when you
initially push at a company to make a
change, incumbent managers will say no.
You need to be persistent enough to be
able to keep pushing and capital to keep
doing it. And finally, you need to do
your homework because this is a
long-term process. And the very best
private equity investors stay in the
game. They stay pushing. They get the
change and they reap the benefits.
I hope you found this session useful and
I thank you very much for listening.